big news just in time for Mother's Day  Janet Jackson is expecting  a source tells ETV iconic singer is  pregnant no word yet on how far along  she is but just a month ago Jackson  announced to fans that she was halting  her world tour because she and her  husband of four years were planning a  family actually has been a sudden change  I thought it was important that you be  the first to know my husband and I are  planning our family it's important that  I do this now I have to rest up doctor's  orders  I will continue the tour as soon as I  possibly can this will be Jackson's  first child and it's all happening just  as she's about to turn 50 her birthday  is May 16th a big congratulations to  Janet